are we rolling yeah
okay all i see is a matching acid wash
color
and and sequins and i'm very excited to
see what this bitch is about to put on
in front of me how dare she i'm going to
get roasted by someone who has crystals
around her eyes yeah i was watching
euphoria makeup tutorials we came out
before i came here bitch annie has not
been to my home in a while and there are
a couple new things i saw you clocking
first i'm just going to put on a shirt
that i really like that i recently
purchased at a thrift store
and now we gotta get our new shirt we
gotta get something new for once how am
i
oh i love it johnny cash we need this
circle over the tit though still not as
many crystals on this shirt as you have
nice people well you know what i got
these while i just by the way did you
just look at the camera oh that one
which one's right there we need to like
annie by the way this is not my side so
i just want you
wow wow that's my girl i don't that's my
fucking girl i have never done this in
the new studio i love it okay this is
really
sad
this is by the way this is true
friendship i have a beauty mark no it is
this is huge but is this usually your
side i'm so uncomfortable over here why
is that well that's normally where i
said but the student but do you have a
symmetric face i have tmj so i always
this is the side i like the best and i
like my beauty mark
on this side
this one i want to get removed everyone
always complains about this when i'm
like send me 500 bucks on venmo and i'll
take care of it i removed a bunch of
moles on this side i just like this one
i love that mole but this one is like a
lower chin one well it was always like
underneath and then i as i aged it just
came out how was that your skin started
getting tighter i got a little fatter
there was more meat in the chin than it
used to be but this is a brand new
studio and i've only done it by the way
it looks great do you like it it's good
right we've only done like 10 in here or
something and i'm already for some
reason so accustomed to that side but no
this side of my face my right side is
like it has nothing like because you
know when they can take a profile of you
one side and they match it yeah and then
if you take both my profile sides and
then mirror them like rorschach tests
like butterflies
totally different face oh really
do you have a favorite
i mean my favorite i get this my right
side i have a dimple in and i don't have
it in my left and it looks just like a
cavernous thing or you don't like the
dimple i don't i'm a fan of dimples
myself well when you're like little to
my thighs no i like my thigh dimples too
my i am so into having cellulite right
now i don't even know no it's i'm like
being a woman i like aging i like being
a woman i like all of it i'm so into it
what is like
why
when i was like in my 20s i needed to be
so skinny and never have any cellulite i
was like buying something well we needed
you to sell a couple shows so we're
happy you did that because now we all
get to be rich
but like what how how is it that i'm
getting more confident as i get older
because i thought i was going to get
more insecure i used to have a plan that
was like oh when i get crow's feet i'll
just blow my head off well we were well
that's how you take care of it
that's called blow talks when you blow
your brain
okay taking a break from us yapping and
yapping to talk about coco floss y'all
this is important i am gonna be honest
about the fact that i used to really not
floss i deluded myself and how much i
was doing it and i was shamed by my
dentist uh
kind of publicly he put it on his
instagram the fact that my dentist has
an instagram's a bigger conversation um
but my gums were bleeding so bad and he
was like why aren't you flossing more
and i had every excuse in the book i
don't like the plastic ones they're bad
for the environment the other ones hurt
your fingers they smell bad they look
ugly but now i have no excuse coco floss
it is like a loofah for your teeth it's
a woven floss made up of more than 500
textures interwoven filaments it's
actually snatches plaque and debris from
in between your teeth and gums and no
one needed it more than emily
coco floss is scented to make flossing
fun our
our favorites are pure strawberry fresh
coconut and delicious mint i love the
strawberry one it's so good it's it is
because you know it's just in your mouth
and it makes the blood taste better a
hundred percent go to cocoa floss top
and i don't even bleed anymore except
from every other hole in your body
crevice go to cocoa floss dot me slash
whitney to get 20 off site-wide and free
shipping check out the four piece set
and you can try four different
fragrances that's
c-o-c-o-f-l-o-s-s-m-e-whitney and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout all lower case letters and
all orders over 20 ship free in the us
i'm going to be coming on may 7th to
vancouver british columbia i'll be at
the vogue theater i have a stand-up
special taping may 13th and 14th in
newark new jersey victoria theater at
the n j pack new jersey pack uh please
don't wear black uh leather cowboy hats
please don't wear straw visors please
don't wear those little uh coily uh
shamrock headbands please don't
wear uh headdresses if it's not
coachella no flower crowns every time i
shoot a special the first three rows is
just it's like a dr seuss impersonator
like cartoonish like full-on remember
the woman that got attacked um that had
the marge simpson hair at the siegfried
and roy i do have the beehive hair if
you thought that tiger got pissed about
that hairdo
watch what happens when i see someone in
the second row at my special taping
wearing a tommy bahama straw hat with
like a kerchief tied around it it's i
know you love it i know you love your
fancy hat your cowboy hat with the with
the burnt matchstick in the sock i know
you think you look cool if you are
if your hair is line is receding if you
are balding i would say go fully the guy
from bruce springsteen who did maybe the
kerchief okay because you can't do hats
right right maybe a beanie a yarmulke a
marker
a
a couple tiny markets whatever needs to
happen because if you are in the first
five rows in a preposterous hat i i do
have to move you or take your hat right
and if you are hiding something up there
just be prepared for that right right
it's happened every one of my special
tapings without my hbo
halfway without fail there was like it
it's not burning man it'll be air
conditioning in there you're set
may 20th tyson's corner virginia i will
be there i used to uh wander around
tyson's corner virginia my mom used to
work there at tysons at the
bloomingdale's there guess what what
never got kidnapped not once
so you guys didn't want me back then but
i feel like i feel like you guys want to
see me now i'll be at the capital one
hall see see what you can do see if you
can fit me in a
pillowcase i
dare you
take her to the bathroom cut her hair
change her clothes
please
help me fake my death
may 21st i'll be in huntington new york
at the paramount i always have such a
good time there june 24th i'll be in
calgary alberta i'll be at prince
prince's island park
it's not famous last week this is how
every
murder documentary starts i'm just gonna
head to prince's
park like what it just sounds too fancy
something bad has to happen june 26th
i'll be in toronto you guys keep asking
me to come to canada i'm listening um
danforth music hall i will be there i'm
going to do some rescheduled shows so
i'm trying to talk faster uh september
8th in cincinnati ohio i'll be at the
taft theater
all the tickets that you bought before
will work september 9th i'll be in
philadelphia pennsylvania i'll be at the
miriam theater september 10th richmond
virginia at the national september 24th
charlottesville
va i'll be there at the paramount
theater charlottesville virginia all my
high school frenemies and enemies show
up let's work this out i love you guys
um and here's andy letterman right yes
ma'am here we go here's some birds of
squawking
anyone with a disability like anything
that's like a physical i'm like you've
been through it even a ginger i like a
ginger because there's a darkness is it
true i was arguing with someone about
this last night not arguing but trying
to figure out is it true or not that
redheads have a higher tolerance for
pain
i don't know like that
i will say listen i'm not like banging
anymore because i love my i'm i'm taken
but but i did enjoy i partaked in the
ginge and they're very sexually
aggressive i'm telling you there's a
there's a if you look into santino's
eyes he is like there's a darkness
inside him they were bullied they were
treated they were told they don't have a
soul and they had to just take it they
just had to take it and take it and take
it and they were put they had plagues
they had slaves starved they didn't have
those
potatoes they no they they had the
potato family oh they didn't have it
imagine not having carbs for 200 years
so jealous they're so lucky but what is
it so what is it exactly okay summary
humans and mice with red hair have a
different tolerance for pain because
their skin's pigment producing cells
lack the function of a certain receptor
lack of this receptor function causes
changes that tip the balance between
pain sensitivity and pain tolerance oh
my god that's why they're fun to bang
you can just
beat the shit out of their dicks i do
know though because i have scotch irish
ancestry which is a little bit different
and the stereotypes were very pugnacious
and uh that's the stereotype of word i
never heard oh cool
i'm like what is that when you have a
lot of pugs i don't know pugnacious let
me try to figure out what pugnacious is
you have an upturned nose you snore what
is that your eyes are on the side of
your head what the fuck is pugnacious
you stupid ivy league bitch
oh my god i'm over here barely able to
read and she's like pugnacious which by
the way her manicure right now says
write a book it says write a book on
notebook paper and i wrote a couple of
words you could have written on a
post-it note too but i don't want to
i know but i was like i needed to be
like really semi-permanent so are you
writing working on writing i did start
yeah i started the book her nails say
write a book for so long she probably
can't type but i know i've waited too
long when i started to grow out i'm like
ooh
audio record a book you're just going to
do an audio book
that's a good idea no no i'm going to
draw i want to draw on mine because i
like to draw so i am uh
a graphic novel is too ambitious
but
[Music]
how do you know when you're done with a
drawing um
i
am bored
no but i no i had an art teacher who
said to me an art professor in college
who said to me um
my friend uh is an artist and she was
asking her like what's advice because
she wanted to make money selling art but
my art teacher is a true artist so she
gave her the best advice she goes
she she asked what you know what's your
advice for like making like an art and
she goes just wake up every morning and
just draw a circle and see like what
comes from that and my friend we left my
friends like what the fuck kind of
advice is that i was like it's the best
advice i've ever heard because it's
about like breaking open your creativity
and while i say that
i will never wake up every morning and
draw a circle but i do wait to be like
divinely inspired if i have an idea and
i never feel like i'm drawing it's
always like
you know right something oh it's like
helping me draw like it just comes
through you yeah and so i've drawn like
such a weird way to that's but that's
what i feel like with stand-ups yeah
yeah when you've got a good joke happens
yeah i'm like i don't even feel like i
i don't know how to explain it yeah no i
thought of it i'm not gonna lie i've
gone on hikes with nick too and
sometimes it is nick to finally speaking
through us and giving us a bit i'm like
nick nick is the most valuable person
on earth you're just talking to him and
he just speaks in punchlines nick is my
best oldest friend who would never i
can't get him on the podcast like i
can't get him he's nervous he's too much
of a weirdo and like he'll like freeze
and he'll just go into some tourette's
mode it's just for us he'll just be like
arabs right like he'll just say
something crazy because he's like got
tourette's but he is the i never know if
other people think he's as funny as i
think he is i find him to be one of the
most hilarious people i've ever met in
my life i'm being dead seriously you
love him emily i adore him i think he's
very by the way you look smoking hot
emily and whitney honestly
i am so sorry for letting you color your
hair that much i didn't realize i looked
like shit until i see this brown back
and i'm like she's was a fucking
fucking
12 out of 10
supermodel and then we let her go
on us
we let her win silly on dude when i went
back to brown hair
people were like you look younger twenty
people i literally look like a child
literally uh people
were rooting for me they're like go
green go blue go back to blue i'm like
all you motherfuckers are all noticed
because you're sabotaging me i know
not that we have children because we're
barren bitches but um our like our
you know when people are like when you
see that you see someone's kid you oh my
god your kid got usually like they did
like they don't because you see them
every day
i saw your hair every day and i i was
like oh that's cool i was pink ish half
pink oh how crazy is that
it's still little roots up here and then
pink down here what a weird interesting
thing well it's also a fortune like i
was like here's here's the deal with it
if you have blue hair
it's it's only cool if you have no roots
as soon as you have the tiniest bit of
ingrown you're drinking i thought you
by the way if my extensions are
obviously showing i don't fucking care
okay i tell the truth but by the way by
the way i tell the truth about my fake
news i tell them all my fake shit okay
the tits are fake too can you believe it
can you believe they made them this big
i've been signing ball stacks i know
you're going to want to i am not do not
i absolutely will not
listen they come no no no listen to the
take back tonight
okay because some guy asked because i
said all my pockets i said guys i've
been signing body parts like buy merch
i'd love for you to support the brand
and everything it's my drawing so i love
like when people buy my art however if
you don't want to buy the merch i'll
sign like us and i i body part and when
i what i mean to be saying is like i
want to sign like nubs and stuff i love
people that have been through some shit
like i really do i'm like you're so cute
i don't want you to feel bad about
yourselves bring your fucking lobster
claws bring your nubs bring all your
shit but then
this guy like dm to me and was like can
i
or he likes he storied me and he was
like well you signed my scrotum i was
like yes of course i'm not going to
discriminate
so then i did a show in brea and the guy
who kept telling me he wanted me to sign
his his scrotum was there and so i go
okay we're going to do it in front of
everyone like the rule is there has to
be public humiliation involved
i'm here to take back the night for all
the ladies out there that have been
put in in weird situations and boys too
but like you know we're gonna have fun
we're gonna play with it
and so i was like come on stage and he
got nervous and i go no no you fucking
started this get your fucking balls up
here and he was like hold on i have to
pee i was like you're gonna go fluff
obviously he's going to fluff but i i
have red bulls on stage i'm like you can
cover your dick with them nobody wants
to see your dick it's this is about the
sound wait don't you pull this going to
wait so the first time i didn't put so
while he was in the bathroom another guy
was like i'll do it so he jumped up so i
so the other guy that started the whole
thing comes back from the bathroom
thinking that he's the one that's
deciding when he's gonna be on and he um
he sees another man like stealing his
thunder
so i i was like new to this i was i was
you know in a little bit of shock so i
just kind of like because the sack is so
wrinkly i just was kind of poking at it
so it wasn't really much of a signature
to hold it you'd have to but nowadays
it's like so amazing to see my full name
on there
like i'll put the francis in i'll anne
francis
and francis letterman the whole thing
but it's like so fun and it's like so
it's just
power ball are they shaved these days i
feel like they're all shaped well i
think people are interested in
anticipation you've seen pubes recently
listen he's half asian one ball's got
hair
but um yeah no it's it's been really fun
why is this already the best podcast
like oh i feel like the last time you
were on i was like really out of it i
was like in a couple well we both were
still in like pretty quiet places it was
the place where i i had a cover doctor
and we had the
i'm so like comfortable surrounded by
asians because my last name is letterman
and my homeroom was always all the
people the last name lee
and i was like oh my god this is like
literally where i'm supposed to be but
they also might just be good people nice
people maybe some of them remember the
virginia tech shooters
i do remember
the chinese government
remember i don't
i just think about like cupcakes and
and flowers i don't think about wars you
can really make an argument that there's
no need to look at news there's no
there's no news there's an addictive
like uh like a masochistic addictive
just adrenaline mindfulness i don't want
to feel bad listen i don't want to feel
bad i'll do my best to live a good life
and and
take care of people in my own circle
remember how like it used to be if you
watched news or read the newspaper you
were smarter than everyone else
this is your inside your brain dude
you are revealing yourself and you know
i mean
i've never ever even attempted to
pretend i was the smartest person in a
room with me it's never even crossed my
mind
to even attempt to say a big word i know
i'm gonna say it wrong
i know my level of education and it's
technically seventh grade
i skipped eighth grade and then i went
to a high school that was for juveniles
where they just jerked off on us i swear
to god i got the lessons were life
lessons they were very sticky
i know how to get out of a sticky i
learned a duck let's just say my teacher
taught me to duck and then when you get
on your knees to suck yes guys listen if
you want to get a d you're going to have
to suck why do i feel like you went to
the school in dangerous minds i listen i
love that you think someone was there to
help it was
we had we had things dots on our hands
the whole time like oh we need you wait
so let me ask you because your brain is
wildly fast and i feel like sometimes
people that are like so naturally smart
and have such quick processing speed you
get bored so fucking easily like you
either did really well in school or
really offline i just wasn't interested
in school it's like i liked math math
felt good like i liked the idea of like
uh
the problem-solving aspect of math it
seemed really cool that they were just
like answers there was like and then
yes exactly math is the truth and i
really enjoyed that but
i never like i would like not be paying
attention and then i'd be like behind i
wouldn't remember what they were saying
so i would miss the lesson and then my
dad told me recently he's like mr jones
your fifth grade teacher or your sixth
grade teacher said that you were
you're really i have a talent in math
you just if you just focused on it you
could really go far and i was like dad
why are you telling me this at 37
i'm like you never told me that
i mean thank god i'd be like a fucking
little i'd be like an engineer right
by the way yeah dad you're not so good
at math because you decided to tell me
this 20 years after i needed to hear
your dad
my dad is making me laugh i called him
recently i was like dad i think i'm
undiagnosed dyslexic and he goes annie
who gives a shit at this point
i was like that is such a good point i'm
not gonna what am i gonna start reading
bonnie mcfarland's book has been sitting
on my i look at it every day doug stand
up i just i'm like literally
i'm manic from hanging out with doug
stanley for two three days he's the
number one yeah he's so funny his his
hour is like crazy doug stanhope is just
one of those comedians if you don't know
who he is look him up he's just like
for comedians like the same way a tell
you know
stan hope is every comedian i feel like
favorite comedian now i feel like he's
now our like carlin or our like lenny
bruce he's fucking amazing you know what
i've been thinking a lot about um
how you know how like people be like
back in our day you know like the older
comedians will be like back in our day
like comedy we really had to like dig
for it and then but it's like you look
back on the stuff and it's like because
we live now i'm looking at their stuff
like it's so hacky yeah i will like look
at the greats and i'll be like i've
heard that a million times
because people have been imitating them
do you know what i mean
we get it black people and white people
you're like
i know neil brennan
i think
i know that's so much well george carl
and i watch it and i'm like
that's a good point
yeah
i i guess back then that was shocking
but they didn't have fucking ticked they
didn't have like 13 seconds people gonna
look back at us and be like all those
ladies and they're clean jokes yeah
they're gonna be like wow they only
talked about squirting for like two
minutes
by the way i squirted
i've become a squirter
i don't want to do my jokes about it
because my my joke about it on stage is
so good but i'll do my jokes about it
just so you know i am not a squirter i
am not squirting
i i am not a squirting lady i don't know
if i'm just dehydrated
if i need more gatorade in my life i'm
not squirting okay i mean if you want i
will compromise and i will pee on you
and then i tried i looked it up and you
can practice it like you can like it's
actually easy you have to just um pee
like when you're fucking yeah you have
to kind of just you just have to just
piss on the person but you have to not
you know what it is it's it's not peeing
it's the fear of peeing that's keeping
you from like peeing doesn't or else it
actually doesn't feel like peeing at all
but it is like a warm because it's not
coming from the same hole
but okay so what is the liquid okay i
don't know it's female ejaculate experts
disagree
uh with what with whether or not it's p
with whether
oscillates out of her vagina
it's not pee but it will mix with
whatever urine is in the bladder at that
time so that's what's fun about it you
can make it pee that's what i like it's
kind of like a you know i it's like um
you know what it is it's like an arnold
palmer you know it's like half lemonade
brown liquid baby
no but it has a mess like
hold on if you've just peed and then you
go squirt five minutes later it's going
to be mostly pure female jackets holy
water do like schmidt oh my god it is
holy water it's whole water
it's holy water
what's the consistency of it it's just
it's very very very
very watery eczema
we now take a break from annie
because this podcast did you write that
go up
let me make sure
i don't know i think that was pat taking
a break right ron annie that was from
pat right pat
yeah exactly i knew you're out to get me
does better help have therapists that
specialize in people that are constantly
mocked by their boss when they make one
tiny mistake even though they never make
any money yes her name is leslie i talk
to her every week
this podcast is sponsored by better
health you're hanging out with my
cleaning lady you guys better not be
friends without me
that's minnie's worth it is that a
healthy thing to say
do i need better help but he doesn't
want to have a funeral she i want
everyone she knows hanging out about her
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours it's not
a crisis line emily so just like this
might not be for you every line i call
is a crisis lab
it's not self-help every room i'm in is
a panic room it's a professional therapy
done securely online and if we had the
internet we would be doing it right now
but our internet is the only hiccup is
we do not have wi-fi they're like we go
to
better help and they're like uh we feel
like first things first um
i feel like you need to call spectrum
and then we'll circle back uh special
cause from the looks of this feat it
seems like your problem is tourette's it
seems like you have a seizure and she's
like are we a seizure we have to maybe
work on the seizures
first
special offer for good for your
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com whitney how about that
and when i'm not
facetiming and zooming with my therapist
i am playing best fiends
you know what's great about buzzfeed's
you don't have to talk to anyone at the
airport they try but you can just hold
it up and they're like oh right
you're like i'm not looking for a best
friend they see them in the middle of
something important they get it they're
like this is important yeah it's just
big killing slugs yeah and what's great
about it is that uh she's facetiming
with tommenburg we don't have internet
right now but we can still play best
thing you know what we do not have
internet right now and the only thing we
can do is play the best feeds i mean
best means if this is part of your
promotional
campaign well done by the way chef's
kiss yeah uh i'm on level 10 well i'm on
level not quite a thousand i'm
exaggerating i'm on level a thousand
because best fiends is a casual mobile
puzzle game that you can play anywhere
right that's why you're on level 1000
yeah because i play it anywhere all the
time i'm up at level i'm on level
without just a little bit and i wrote
level 1000 and i wouldn't want to
do they have the capacity for being
embarrassed that's hilarious very true
that's kind of hilarious so i did not
know that was your line yeah no i'm
sorry i i could have made it more clear
um
no i no i feel like that would be
something oh yes my bad will definitely
be on your gravestone my gravestone will
i i should have been more clear
that's my way of saying you should have
understood what i said it should have
been more clear means fuck you i should
have been more clear means like you're
an idiot yeah yeah collect tons of means
that you can bet
collect tons of themes that you cannot
be unclear that that's you're an idiot
that i should have been more clear is
like
that's the big guy i just i should have
been yeah collect tons of fiends that
you can power up as you play more levels
every win brings new challenges there
are thousands of puzzles to play
download best fiends for free from the
app store or google play i feel like you
should be more clearer plus or about
where i wanted to work plus earn even
more with five dollars worth of in-game
rewards when you reach for level five
that's friends without the r best fiends
back to annie what's it like to have
such cool friends though emily
i don't have friends i have fiends
what did you find out because i want to
hear about this it is
they don't know but they believe that
it's a combination of urine and fluid
from the female prostate gland i
i know i had a button falling out of my
ass i know it is like am i growing a
dick out of my body
well i might naturally by the way i
don't know like how pc this is to say by
the way transition babies do your thing
happy for you here's the body for you to
be happy literally the only thing about
the trans stuff that is like when i have
friends that have kids in l.a and
they're picking their gender like five
six it's none of my business what is
fucking right
i'll do whatever you tell me to say i'll
give a shit if i forget sorry
yeah yeah if i say the wrong thing is on
purpose
so if i say your pronoun wrong i also
don't know your name get me on that yeah
also i don't know what an adverb is so i
don't know what a fucking pronoun is
fucking mad either with me and you'll
see that i don't know what a fucking
pronoun is call it like i've never sweat
more than when someone's like all right
we're doing mad libs they're like all
right two adverbs i'm like what yeah it
has
someone else take this i don't know what
these things
i think about that all the time
literally the funny that's how you
squirt think about it at the right time
hold on let's not for okay will you tell
about your bed their adjustable bed oh
yes oh i have um i have a like a
hospital bed i ordered one of those
hospital beds and so
uh my boyfriend and i
he's very tall so he'll just stand at
the edge of the bed and then we'll have
sometimes i have the remote sometimes he
has it and then i just i scooch my my
bottomless body to the edge to the
corner and then we just we just go z
and then i lift up to his penis level
and then we sometimes it's
we go up and down but that's pretty slow
you have to wait for the motor to kick
in and stuff but i present my vagina to
him it's really
i i can't recommend it enough
i can't it is so good and it prepares
you for getting molested in the old
folks home which is going to happen all
of us can say or it's like it reminds me
of like when you're in stirrups at the
guy now it just sucks that your mom is
in one of those beds so that probably
makes you feel bad you're like are they
that is true but hers moves way faster
this is like a real one
medical grade medical equipment where do
your legs go on you i'm on the corner of
it okay but your legs have to be on them
so i'm on the very edge okay got it okay
and your legs are dangling my legs are
dangling it's great but then they're
around him right
is there um like a piece of paper on top
of the bed yeah there's a piece of paper
he's wearing gloves i don't know why i'm
picturing like paper wrinkling but is
that doctor wang long
i knew he was going to be a little
pricey when he gave me a cell phone
number one oh
what are you doing
oh boy we're not going to get the
discount on this one
also by the way that he is the greatest
because he said to me when i went in and
froze eggs he was like you might never
use these yes but the freedom it's going
to give you to move through the world
just knowing you have it and he brings
out his uh candies he shows you with his
starbursts but it's funny when you go in
you can see that like other people have
been eating they think it's like a thing
of starburst he shows you like whether
you have good eggs or bad eggs with
these two different colored he has
yellow and orange orange and cherry
which is of course the best and then oh
he didn't even have any cherries for me
oh i probably ate them no you probably
went in when you were younger than me he
told me that i have the uterus of a 34
year old i was like thank you so much
he did not tell that he didn't say he
said that to me when i was 13. he said
you have the pussy of a 13 year old this
is gorgeous you did this 32. you did
this work
did you ever get any vag stuff done no
wait that's not true i remembered this
the other day i went to i can say who it
is dr lancer
had a ulthera it was like a laser wait
is that the one that was supposed to
tighten your vagina it was like a wand
and i did go in for three sessions you
know i feel like you're you run so like
like tight tight
there's no way i actually when i when
you went to raquel oh there's my massage
like jesus did you know when you went to
rehab no oh my god i was like i'm gonna
visit with you i didn't get to go to the
family
i'm so jealous i would have known if i
went to rehab well i would have told
them
yes i know that i never need to deliver
news to anyone i know andy will do it
for me she has to wait like she gives me
a wink when it's okay okay if i was in
rehab i'd be like hey guys rehab here
like i don't know
but we'd be in a good one i'd be with
you codependent everyone would know i'd
be like i'm a betty ford hashtag paid
partnership anymore thank you so much
for getting me sober you guys are the
best betty boss
hashtag
um
what were okay when i went to rahel so
rahel is she told me i was doing a kegel
forever she does the grinberg method
which is a is a uh i've talked about
this book a lot of the podcast the body
that keeps the score where you hold old
trauma in your muscles and based on the
way that you reacted to traumas growing
up or like shrunk yourself or a lot of
times women's shoulders because we're so
apologetic and need to minimize
ourselves or we have bad posture
whatever and that when something i was
actually ducking from semen teacher so
that was what i was like oh no coming to
bob and weave oh my god
and so she goes in and finds all the
places that you like hold tension and
basically it's like you get naked you're
lying there in your panties and she like
touches your shoulder and you squirt out
of your eyes
you become quite as i squirt her and you
cry for about two hours yeah oh yeah
it's really it's wild we're both dating
younger guys i don't know why
i haven't like
thought about that for some reason i am
just
why am i so and look i i you know it
took me so long to surrender to dating
somebody younger because the three
things i thought i needed in
relationships was a guy that's taller
than me
physically and alex like is my
when i'm barefoot he's a little taller
alex climbs you bitch he climbs you like
a fucking tree and listen i love alex
i'm a team alex i've been team alex this
whole fucking time you probably have
been when you were pretending you
weren't team alex i was still team alex
that's right remember there was one time
where he came over and he had um uh he
had super glued his eyes shut i was
still team alex okay wearing sunglasses
anyway you were like i don't know about
his attitude today or something and i
was like yeah i feel like he's in a bad
mood and then later he was like yeah i
so i fucking super glued my eyeshadow
yeah i was like why does he keep winking
at me he's flirting with me
because when you're he's a he rock
climbs and you have to super glue wounds
together basically while you're climbing
to you put super glue in them and
continue that's actually how the doctor
tightens your vagina that was the same
laser that he is they just super close
well the irony is like dating a rock
climber everyone's like that's so hot
i'm like no his fingers are just fucking
nasty cats oh my god you got those hard
titties
well no here's the other thing about
rock climbers is that they have to keep
their hands dry at all times and he's
perfect
jesus because the woman he did before me
was like three years older than me oh
that's good when you're the young one
dude when he goes to yeah i'm like a hot
young like dude for him my yoga
instructor is fucking incredible who's
now she's moved on to a skincare line
that's good i don't even know what the
name of it but i'm wearing it it's
amazing but she i like love her so much
she's listening to her right now being
like
see it i'll say it at another i'll say
it somewhere else can you it's so good
it's ursula i'll hand i'll handle you
guys you guys will know about it but she
um
she came over to like drop off the
products and um she met todd and she was
like oh my god she's 10 years older than
me she's like oh my god he's amazing
like
i mean she's like does he have a does he
have an older brother i'm like his own
his older brother is eight years younger
than me so
sorry man there's no such thing i just
feel like there's like we talk so much
right now about like isms like
homophobia racism sexism we don't talk
enough about ageism and i was ageist i
totally was i was like you know you just
assume like younger like younger guys
are like punks and they're like
don't appreciate women and dead i have i
can argue you that
it's the older guys that i feel like
they're broken and they see women as
fucking obvious old guys are punks oh
god no it's just not that it's just more
like i always thought in order to get
more mature you'd have to go older
that's what i thought too until todd
listen when i first started dating todd
it was it was moments before the
pandemic okay he was just like basement
todd i called him he worked in the
basement of the comedy store he was so
cute he was from jersey remind me of
home can i say something really quick
yes did you feel like i feel like i have
avoided or not dated a lot
of really amazing men because they were
too nice
and my brain goes like oh that person is
nice either i don't deserve that or i i
like don't respect that person or like
they must be dumb yeah like yeah like
well it's not even i don't even think
like i don't think it's that i like i
think when i was unhealed like when i
wasn't working on myself i was
so bored by like kindness was like this
is not the thing that gets my adrenaline
i was so like addicted to the roller
coaster of like being conflict yeah like
triggered all the time and i mean i was
like
my neighbors used to slide things under
my last my boyfriend before him or two
boyfriends before him um would slide
like notes under a door that's like do
we need to call the cops like because we
would just be screaming and slamming
shit and i was like a slam i don't i my
like anger outbursts are god like i must
miss them so i remember one time with
alex like i was just testing him a lot i
was because also him being younger made
me feel insecure because well first of
all the three things i thought i needed
was taller than me a vet bigger
free vet services that's what i needed
no a war vet with no life so they can't
leave me they can never hobble out of
here they'll find a way they'll army
crawl out i was always good at crawling
i always had such fucked up and i'll
sign that
when she tosses you out you come to my
shower and i'll sign your bottles and
your nubs my bed crawls because he's
literally a child i have a little baby
uh but uh uh bigger than me because
that's what made me feel small yes and i
hit such fucked up body dysmorphia i was
like i can never date a guy that's
thinner than me it just would like weird
me out but i always had better sex with
little guys that's all it's always the
case but here's what's like
the only thing hotter than a guy who's
five fucking you know
inches taller than you is the guy who is
your height who's like yeah what's up
i'm gonna fuck your brains out and there
and it's actually more alpha yeah no it
doesn't matter
i'm gonna fuck the shit out of you
they're like no you're taller than me
and he's wearing your heels in bed
like and i'm into it do you know what i
mean he yeah todd okay so todd's 6'3
which is so good
he's so cute he's also just like always
laughing he's always in such a good mood
he's always laughing i tell you
something it is so fucking healed of you
for you to be able to receive the kind
of love that he gives
and like the consistent positive energy
that he puts out it's amazing
he's just like wearing stripes and
laughing let me ask you something for
people smoking a cigarette because when
you're kind of like vaping there's a
certain point where like i think for me
when you're in so many bad relationships
by the time a good person comes along i
find that everything they do is like
suspicious like like when i met alex
like he'd be like hey how was your day
i'm like who's asking yeah
like is it you know your inner child
it's always like the whole show with
flowers i'm like what did you do let me
see your phone honestly flowers are
suspicious i think
flowers are like we were just thinking
about that when i played those it's like
if they're from ralph's they did
something like if they're like last man
like oh shit like the flower store is
closed you know for people that are
consistently in bad relationships it's
like you go like oh i guess i'm my
picker's just off i guess i'm just like
always gonna recreate my childhood
circumstances whatever and then it's
tricky because then you get a point
where
you stop gravitating you wouldn't
gravitate anyone healthy because people
like well this person's always an
unhealthy relationship you're just like
you get what you expect etc like when
todd came along do you feel like you
were i'd already done enough work to be
able to receive that or do you feel like
he came in your life and you're like
i was right on the edge of it like i was
right on the edge but i was go i was
burning really fast like i i was going
like as fast as i could everything i was
doing it was just like
like everything all the time stand up
stand up stand up everything like
so feeling like i had to follow a
certain path to a specific thing and
then when todd came along he was like i
remember he would like he's he um slept
over
and i missed like a meditation class or
yoga or something i was like freaking
out i was like i missed my fucking class
like now i'm gonna miss jujitsu i was
waking up doing a meditation class hot
yoga then jiu jitsu then writing like i
had like everything kind of like planned
and it was like not sustainable i get
headaches and stuff because i'm like so
i yeah i hold on too tight so but i was
i was like he had that routine and i
remember he like fucked the routine up
and i was like and it wasn't it was like
because i was like feeling love feelings
and happy and we're just in the moment
yeah
and i was like you're fucking ruining my
shit already and he was like don't you
just want something that can like tell
me what your schedule is i'll help you
get up for it i'll like don't you want
someone that just like loves and
supports you know like scram kids are
yoga and meditation to relax meanwhile
you're actually relaxed in bed with this
guy i would be screaming like i need to
go right now
yeah but so then so then the pandemic
hit right when we had been dating for
like two weeks and i kept telling them
like this is not like a long-term thing
like i'm gonna just like i will drop you
at some point you don't fit my
that's what i said to alex truly and he
was like no he's like whatever he was
like i think i'm good for you and i was
like that is the hottest shit to be like
cool bitch and this is without the first
time i pulled my like bullshit which i
think half was like testing him because
i think my brain was so ageist i was
like well he's immature and he's not
ready for this and he doesn't want
something scary to take off my important
you're shrugging you're a little shrug i
know i'm sorry the fucking air
conditioning is brought up no that's
okay i i i i also pretend the quote air
conditioning is broken so that girls
will just take off all their clothes
that's a
sexual predator move i've learned
in hollywood that's so cute i know it's
like a shimmer yeah i brought a shirt
it's like a good shimmer what's it where
is it from your body shimmer
because it's like not too much it's the
perfect everything i'm wearing just in
case you want it's the perfect amount of
like luminescence
but i remember when um
i pulled some oh cute shimmer oil with
sarans
anastasia anastasia oh that's the
eyebrow girl that's really good that
girl's a queen and so um he i pulled
some shit with him that was just like
who's that like it was just he is a vet
and vet is a very
uh female dominated profession all his
like resident mates and best friends are
like female that's what you guys have in
common
you have in common that you're in like
the wrong gender job
but so i was doing something like oh who
is that and he's like oh my resume i'm
like cool what like just pulling some
shake jealous bullshit
let's see what you got bitch let's see
because i used to equate
um
like
truculent or like
being willing to fight like that's how
i'm going to see how smart you are
trunculin
like what's the word when you like want
to fight all the time it is pugnacious
that is
being a joe rogan fan i don't know
antagonistic
antagonistic yeah it's just like let's
see exactly i should dumb it down for me
it's so cute
but just
i don't know
i can't read bitch but just like trying
to yeah i know what you mean yeah like
let's fucking see what you got well
listen and he literally i was like doing
that and he was just like
what are you doing yeah they just see
you doing the movie i know he it was he
was like oh
he was like
does this usually work for you you like
wouldn't let him come to things and
stuff you were like the party's starting
you need to leave
yeah i was like that too i mean todd
like okay i was like we're not together
but here's the thing the pandemic hit
right okay so todd was like saying all
that stuff
and by the way before the pandemic hit
the three weeks that we were together
when i was like we're gonna break up i
opened for louis ck that's my boy he
didn't pull his penis out i was almost
disappointed um i was like uh your
reputation is off
i've never looked hotter he and he can
take the hit because he's a ginger and
they
no i fucking i absolutely love louis but
um so i opened for him in like denver or
something
and so i was only gonna be gone for one
night and todd was like working at the
comedy store and his apartment was far
away so he was like can i stay at your
place because it's close to work and i
was like stay in my place when i'm out
there okay
and i was like you can do it but then i
was like what if he like brings i don't
know him like what if he brings like
girls to my house i come home he brought
his playstation he moved into my home
he did the complete opposite he moved
into my house and i was like oh my god
what am i going to do with this guy and
then the pandemic hit and i was like
we'll just stay through this like short
quarantine
and then you know
12 years later here we are
also like
a younger guy it's kind of night when
you're dating an older guy the biggest
bummer dude is like when you open drawer
like in the bathroom there's like
covergirl lipstick from like 89. that
they put on when you're not there
it's like they've been freaked
out listen and i never i dated older
guys they were never divorced they were
just
loser commit no offense sorry they're
not i don't wanna say the losers because
i don't wanna harbor any results they're
losers are you comfortable sharing the
aged gap like how you when we're saying
young how many so let's see
the one was yeah one word no i mean now
todd yeah oh it's time for 11 years
i'm eight or nine i'm not sure how we'll
do this okay i just i yeah no i anytime
i can't even scroll like his face and
ask him about it i scroll through his
like profile pics if i go like four
picks he's a kid i'm like
uh mom like sent me his graduation
picture i was like bitch do not send me
this are you reminded that because to me
alex is so much more emotional
exactly
in general yes but when are times when
you're like this is an age thing um
very rarely he knows everything for some
reason i don't know why he knows other
things he knows every
every lyric to every atlantis moore sets
out yeah like he was like for whatever
because my thing is like if we don't
have to say music references like when i
dated a much older guy it was just like
i'm like i don't know james taylor like
i don't i'm sure he's i know james
taylor but i'm sure i was hoping you
were going to be like i don't know i
don't know if i'm going to lose like
holland oates on a road trip like it's
just not like i try to you're naming
some hits
cause you wanna you know what though i
my dad
the only music i listened to as a kid
was music my dad played before we go to
work so my dad would stay up all night
this is why i fight the night like my
dad like we do not want to go to sleep
we try to stay up as late as we can well
he had to go he had to be at work at
like six or seven so he would like be up
until like one or two and then he would
be up at four getting ready because he
has 80d so it would take a while so my
dad would be out tired and he'd have to
jack himself up by blasting music he
would play like the eagles and james
taylor
and like moody blues and stuff but he
and hall notes but he would play i
remember he would play hotel california
and my brother was like dad that was
like the scariest shit cause we were
like still in that subconscious like
floating phase of still being kind of
asleep yeah so you're like absorbing the
setup yeah yeah yeah it's like but you
can never leave max was like what the
hell yeah was like you can check in but
you could never leave janna's shopping
all that stuff so like kind of the only
music i like and
and um like elton john but you but then
you date older guys and you're like oh
you remind me of my dad
that makes sense
you're calling me a cup oh that's why i
know how to use a record player you
always apologize when i say oh my god i
got the comedy show record player too we
were just playing it earlier pat got me
a uh and then elena's motorcycle record
and we played it it was so fucking
jagged pillow it actually works i did
not think it would work let's be honest
i know it works better than the sound
system at the comedy story i know i'm
like yeah do you want us to bring this
in but here's the other thing about
dating older guys like it's weird
because i was trying to work on a bit
about this and i just like couldn't it's
almost like too incendiary to talk about
which is like this whole like
younger girls dating older guys now is
like a problematic it's a good abuse of
power like that when you grow up without
money that was like your parents would
encourage you to do that it was like the
nicest thing your parents could do it
was like oh yeah go with the guy that
can like take you to
restaurants my parents girl my parents
okay you know you said nobody talks
about ageism my mom was a worked at this
organization um
when i was a kid called gray panthers
which was just like an organist by the
way way to steal the fucking names from
the wait what they called up grey
panthers and the woman that that ran it
that i was that i knew was this like
nine year old woman who his name was
maggie coon
i'm like it was k-u-h-n but i was like
um
tricky i'm like this is
speaking of a word that doesn't exist
back then problematic
but um
so she was always like ageism was kind
of like a thing we talked about all the
time and it was always like grey
panthers was like a pro it was like yeah
it was like helping the elderly and
stuff but then they all died oh and it
ended but she but i learned from maggie
coon the quote um the best age to be as
the age you are and that has like saved
my life because i do feel that way i'm
always like present in the moment loving
my age but of course my age hasn't
gotten
shaky yet
yeah
the reason i'm telling you that is what
were you saying no i'm just saying like
i think that like this is a hot take i
dated older guys because i needed
someone that
oh okay but hold on really quick my
parents our parents the the in that
maybe it's kind of more of a southern
thing too whereas like the idea of
dating a teenage boy your age is much
worse because they're gonna like
show photos of you naked to their
friends they don't know how to fuck yeah
yeah they're gonna crash their dad's
truck when they're totally
they could be like okay this is like an
adult
that you're dealing with that's not okay
who's gonna make you like play chicken
and then but
i have a theory that like it's actually
why i got smart like i dated yes of
course creepy older guys that were like
preying on me but i was like using them
you were praying for them
i was using um them as much as they were
using me and i remember like that's a
really part of a big part of how i got
smart because i had to like talk to
older people and like he had books and i
would like read them and the older
people that prayed on me did not want me
to talk like an adult it was the last
thing they wanted
can you go down in age
uh we are taking a quick break from the
conversation with a e to talk about
another podcast that is very worth
listening to there is a podcast it is
called life is short justin long he
chats with celebrities actors musicians
artists and more about how they get the
most out of life how do we make the most
of our time here on earth well i
certainly don't know how do we bring
meaning to our lives at work how do we
you know find the best emoji to use when
texting these are the important
questions asked in this weekly interview
podcast listen to the life is short with
justin long on apple podcast amazon
music or you can listen one week early
and add free by joining wondering plus
in the wondery app
but i'm saying like that's how i learned
about like like got worldly and learned
like how to run a business because i was
dating a guy that ran a restaurant he
was older and like my no one taught me
about money as a woman like a girl like
no one taught me i learned it by dating
older guys i kind of was an advantage
that i had in a weird way my dad used to
make us play this game called cash flow
but i didn't understand what it was to
try to teach us about money yeah it's
like a money game it was like a board
game about money but i don't fucking
remember it but i was probably high do
you know many times i was like on acid
in front of my family and they didn't
know i was just always such a little
druggie kid is that true yeah i remember
my mom being like we're going to we're
going to the store and i was like fuck i
just dropped acid
so we went to the store and i remember
being stuck in the candy aisle for a
while and then like look at my brother
like is that a girl or boy and this is
before there were that many
questionables
questionables of their gender not
questionable of their
intention and the gender
and so why wait okay so my mother i do
want to know what drugs have that
microdose that what they do to your mind
well i want to say my mom did not raise
me to marry a rich guy and i look back
when i go bitch
you could have been like make your own
wealth and also
date a rich guy hurt because
date a guy that has so many do you know
how many times i had a like i always had
a dream of like throwing some guy's
stuff out the window but it was always
like kind of mine i was like wait that
was the thing he borrowed from my life
there's really like there's a trash bag
with like a couple of shirts in it it's
not gonna like fucking mean anything
what are the things that
really do you feel like changed you
changed your neurology
like
okay in a big way if you were to
recommend to like a person like here's
like five things that changed my mind
okay i would recommend who i am today
right now i would recommend actually not
drugs i would recommend hypnosis and
subconscious reprogramming i would
recommend this guy jim foreign his
podcast has like changed everything
it's about subconscious it's like brain
based like studies and stuff about like
um just subconscious reprogramming and
stuff and it's all like it's just all
like working on like focusing your brain
where you want it like kind of not
living in a victim mentality it's really
good like figuring out what thoughts are
true and which aren't like it was such a
fucking mind fuck for me when i learned
in program that feelings aren't facts i
was like what like everything i think is
true and then when you realize like your
memory is not like always correct and
you're just really hanging on to stuff
but dude like maureen surf this is
actually really gonna get me canceled
because it's like it's like believe
women but also memories are vlogs yeah
like morin surf he's coming on the
podcast he has a bunch of ted talks
about this he's a neuroscientist to talk
about how
no one really remembers anything
accurately and it's this elephant in the
living room that we're not allowed to
talk about because our memories are so
biased and flawed yeah like no two
people will remember an incident the
same way well i like the elephant to be
in the bedroom because that's why i used
to get so black out drunk to fucking
because i was like one of us needs to
forget this but don't write elephants
do not in the bedroom or elsewhere and
do not uh get necklaces of their
tusks no do not do that by the way when
i go down to la jolla whenever i do the
comedy store in la jolla it is so weird
to walk around it they just have ivory
in the fucking store really yes it's
wild do you realize that that ivory what
was it can you look up the gifts for
every wedding anniversary i think ivory
is still on there they're a real
christmas town did you know that dr
seuss came from is from that area and
that's why he wrote the grinch because
they're like obsessed with christmas la
jolla's like you're inside a christmas
club it's a weird little place it's such
a weird little like i do like it though
i don't know about the i
don't support the animal cruelty it's a
very rich suburb of san diego and i'm
not sure seals like they're on the beach
they're just seals chilling there's like
four or five toys like attacks like navy
ones like
there aren't any deals too that's where
they do their training
and no but it's like walruses like their
whiskers and fucking
what is that now what is it up to how
many people have died of taking selfies
this year
i think 327 was how many people had been
taking selfies and fell off cliff so
i'll tell you what it's happening now
there's no way three just died now and
uh uh so many people that have died
taking photos with wild animals i almost
fucking died on the way here like going
up the fucking canyon and shit i was
like i gotta take a picture of my
euphoria because i thought of a pun i
wanted to take a picture and go it's
more like me for ya
and it's just i almost died and then as
i was almost dying i saw a fucking prius
literally in the bushes and thank god
there was a bush because it would have
gone like straight down into the thing
and these two kids like dude literally
there's a video that is i do not
recommend that you google it of a guy
trying to take a selfie with a bear and
it just starts eating him but he's still
snapping he's still strapping that's a
whitney move and there's there's so many
people we're going to talk about like if
i just love to spare enough we're going
to talk about the extension we mentioned
this on my show
i went to whitney's um halloween party
okay it was for her june shine whereas
oh that's right where's the june show
i'm holding one right now actually but
this is not my flavor my favorite okay
that flavor fucking sucks okay okay get
the other one get the whitney brand okay
i i don't feel like we got to hang out
that much
my hair caught on fire oh that's right
my extension went up in flames i was
talking to your agent or your manager i
was talking to your manager he was
dressed as gold and then his boyfriend
was a gold digger and when there are hot
days around i am going to do whatever
they say i was like whipped i was like
hello boys
and so i was i was a um i went as a
slutty shaman and i just like just
dressed like a whore and had a bucket
that's right and i had a bucket with um
and i drew a third eye on my forehead
incense yeah
it actually was a brilliant
it was great it was a great costume for
like a place where like people weren't
actually like drunk and enjoying
themselves but yours was very well
thought out and like well committed to
and and that's always sometimes that can
be cringey and you like nailed it um
what were we talking about what we were
talking about uh subconscious
programming
this is like when you go like but to get
this person this first person hates me
i'm never gonna like when you're able to
go like no those are just thoughts
they're right
like i'm now like spinning a story in a
narrative and all i need to do i'm
having a feeling that's not productive
for me and so what i can do now is use
these tools whether it's like breath
work or
i've been doing breath work again which
is so fun okay and explain what that is
breath work well there's a bunch of
different types of breath works but
please tell me you're not gonna get a
tattoo that says breathe i'm not getting
any tattoos
do you have none none that's wild todd
wants me to get one but what does he
want you to get probably a crab or
something he's like of course that we
always eat crab legs if todd's like
doubling down against like he has a
lobster tattoo and he wants to get like
a crab on his neck with a with a crown
so it's like king crab i'm like all
right let's just obsession with crabs we
just eat i mean we eat seafood all the
time the love of his life had crabs in
college i don't know
your pussy smells like gloves yes like
what oh my god esther just tweeted she's
like what is cmos i was like it's the
stuff between your legs bitches are
manscaped is that true no but i don't
see mosses but isn't that such a good
idea it's a good name for fucking pubes
cmos
um
but wait what we're talking about so
you're doing breath breath work is like
you just okay so the one i do it's
um my friend sophia is uh
does it for me and i met her at this
like
this breath work place before the covet
obviously that was like the first class
to get cut his breath work just
breathing covered on each other yeah but
she does a method that's like you
breathe like it's always through your
mouth and you breathe to your stomach
your chest and out
because we mostly breathe with our
diaphragm only and we're supposed to
breathe out of our stomach it moves
trapped emotions i don't care if it
sounds woo-woo and hippy should it
fucking you are oh it deactivates your
amygdala that's real so you can't
simultaneously uh reduce i'm sorry you
can't simultaneously release cortisol
and take deep breaths so cortisol is
emitted so you can make yourself emit
cortisol whenever you want if you start
just going and taking like cortisol is
actually pee did you know that
so i'm just like always i could then i
could swear in that case i made
constance murder but when you're the
stress hormone cortisol which makes you
gain weight it makes your attention slow
down it makes your brain shut down your
frontal lobe cut off like when you're
taking deep breaths that's your brain's
way of going oh we're in trouble it's
just so hard to not to like in that
moment when you're getting triggered
like when i'm getting like filled up
with like blood you know when you like
get triggered and you just feel like
blood rises like the word triggered now
became like you're so delicate that
people have to walk around actually you
know where the words are being
like well i swear schneider wait no rob
schneider told me this i just was
talking to him on the phone i love me my
brother
he goes love him he was like the
triggered safe space all the stuff
that's those were words for autism those
were for and i used to be a special ed
teacher or camp counselor and so i know
all like i knew all this shit
um
but i when he said that i was like oh my
god it is so now we're just all
acknowledging we're like that word like
has just lost its like it's now like
here's what here's what i want to say
about it and i didn't mean to hile
hitler to get the attention yeah
i was like no honestly like the thing
with it and like we've i said this on
your last podcast you know there's a
thing i would say i would say twiggered
instead of trigger because i'm being a
baby
i'm being a child i just say twiggered
but it is like i love this like yes like
mental health awareness all that stuff
it's time to now work through it guys
like i'm it's done i don't think we need
to end there it's like now like i just
i'm learning all these tools i'm trying
i'm gonna do this thing with spotify
coming out soon that's like i'm gonna do
all my like hippie woo shit on it i
don't know what it's called yet but it's
it's coming it's gonna be like um
just audio and stuff so i can have
people come on and like talk to them and
stuff but it's gonna be really fun and
if i'm not funny on it we're not doing
it i'm gonna put it behind and pay where
you're gonna have to pay to see me be
not funny but but i do like i think i'm
learning all these tools and i'm just
like putting them out there when i learn
them because
and take them if you want them if not
but it's like because i just it's like
i'm tired of like okay i was diagnosed
with this thing and now it's like i had
a friend in in college who was diagnosed
bipolar and i was like dana you're not
like you've never seemed bipolar to me
like even a little bit yeah and of
course i only knew her for four years or
whatever eight um
took a while
but
but she then like kind of and i don't
know what it is i don't know what
happened but then she went like kind of
wild and i was like i don't know if it
was like this permission in her or
whatever
and i'm not going to speak on anyone
else's mental illness or anything but
it's like
it's very exciting for me to have found
these tools that are really helping me
just get in touch with how i feel what
i'm doing what's like
what i want to like project into the
world yeah but i think that like the
mental illness conversation right now
it's like it's it's like great we're
talking about mental illness but you
being diagnosed with a mental illness
like they're that's a great first step
in order to figure out like how am i
going to move through it doesn't mean
everyone needs to walk on eggshells
around my mental illness right because
that's actually like narcissism and
egomania which is not allowed let's just
say if i get diagnosed with something
you guys will never i'm taking that to
the grave it's not your it's not
everybody else's thing because they're
struggling with their own shit and it's
magical thinking to go because i see a
lot of people are so desperate right now
to self-diagnose to something they want
so badly to have anxiety disorder well
there are people that actually have it
if you're tweeting about it five times a
day and instagramming
chances are you don't have fucking time
that depends on what time period it is
if it's in the middle of the night maybe
you have it
all you do is post about how anxious you
are why don't you have anxiety about how
much you're boring me with these fucking
posts where you're just trying to be a
victim yeah so it's like it's not well
the currency became victimhood and i
think after um this pandemic i think
we're done with that i think it's like
we all were victims now we're getting
put out we all were very too much time
to like self-obsess
and feel sorry for ourselves and i think
it's it's hard for like women like us
because we are supposed to be like
paying attention to kids like we are
supposed to like naturally have children
at this point but like maybe even be
grandmas
i feel like we're supposed to be raising
our kids yes i can't believe i wasn't a
pregnant teen that had a pregnant teen
like but so it is interesting to have
all this sort of like excess like energy
to focus on ourselves where you're not
it's not like on a kid i'm grateful for
that because um if and hopefully when i
do have kids i'm gonna have work through
all my shit and like and but also having
a little bit of shit like they're
they'll also be fine yeah do you know
what i'm saying it's like that's the
other thing is that like i'm not saying
like at first it's good for kids like
don't do it on purpose but like you know
for me i feel really lucky that
you know my parents were inconsistent
and like they weren't around a lot or
there was alcoholism in my family
because it prepared me for like actual
life and i see people that were raised
in these like very secure homes and like
they just are not prepared for the world
and they're the ones that are like fuck
you you said that one thing you're
cancelled because you made one mistake
when you were 18. it's like not
everybody was well it's like when
um
comfort and pleasure is not actually
like
what life is like you're not like
you're not entitled to comfort and
pleasure all the time you can like i
i've really learned on how to like learn
how to like look at things where i do
kind of like choose joy and i do have
fun all day but it's like and it seems
to build the more i do that but it's
like i did go through a lot of shit it
was uncomfortable and i got through it i
fucking laughed the whole time yeah but
i had a good time there's well there's
something like when when i just feel
like i'm at a place where i'm so
grateful for all the bad things happen
to me when i'm yes because i'm like what
are you gonna like you move through the
world in this invincible way because
you're just like the shoe can't fucking
drop
like in relationships i can be so
fearless because i'm like what do you do
break my heart yeah do you say like but
then it does then you're like oh my god
i'm back here again i thought i would
never feel this way again oh my god but
like it's just like i don't know i just
think that there's this new thing where
people are like i remember when i went
to dr david agus and i was i was uh
talking about like oh well maybe i have
a tighter pussy which one is that doctor
dr david agus was that the pussy
titanium doctor no not in the slightest
he's an oncologist to usc
whose career you just ruined
no that's just uh watermelon mint
fizzy one that's delicious um and uh and
i said i was like i just think i have
like a lot of anxiety and he was like he
just looked at me he was like
isn't it kind of serving you in a lot of
ways yeah and i was like just kidding
from this ocd we're all like obsessed
and like be a perfectionist like about
something and i don't know we love it
we're very grateful i'm like i should
rewrite a joke like 10 times and he's
like well you charge people money to
come to you i mean you probably should
be a little bit of a perfectionist
oh everything because if you just look
at things i've been working on like
detaching and and not like
not like claiming things as my own like
i would always be like oh my cluster
headaches my tmj my teacher the molester
my thing like they're not they're just
things that happen and i'm like
obviously don't molest kids it's
horrible that i was molested however i
am now like going out and i'm like i'm
doing all these jokes about being
molested and people are coming up like
thank you so much and i'm like oh my god
i literally know why i'm on this earth
like this to get fucking diddled and
then to help people like un burden
themselves of this thing and be like
fuck it dude sublimate this into art
because it's like i'm not going to let
this person that did this fucked up
thing to me this time i left them at my
life i let you have my they have no clue
they're not even thinking about it
they're not
thinking about me fucking over 20 years
ago they don't feel bad they're not
losing sleep at night but i am and it's
also it's like i'm not going to be
riddled with shame because you did the
bad thing i'm saying like i took on your
consequences like i didn't even realize
like i did this meditation there's this
woman michelle chauffeunt who i really
love and
um she has a podcast called the adult
chair that i really enjoyed
um i don't do i don't listen to it that
much anymore because i'm doing all the
jim ford and stuff but she's like
incredible and she i found her the way i
even found jim ford and all these people
was i just randomly was like so remember
when i was obsessed with that one guy i
was dating-ish
and it wasn't what that was and i was so
there this is when you and i really like
i think became close because you were
doing something that i had done so many
times which is like you're in an
entrenched codependent relationship
where it's like you start conflating
love and pity
the person actually does kind of need
you but is also an adult you start sort
of like rescuing them and you get into
this kind of entrenched like obsessed
yeah completely and
and you go offline it's like if you were
to see someone else do it it's so easy
to know if you had seen me doing that
you would know exactly but when you're
in it you just and you were like you
said i remember you were like don't go
to the problem for the solution because
i kept like going back to him and being
like
i just need to talk to him about that
right i just need to ask him this and
i'm like well you're going to the
problem for the solution right because
you're so fixated on them like i didn't
i'm so grateful for that too and like no
hard feelings or anything but it's like
it very much was like that was the shift
and then it was taught after that todd
and i have such a good it's so fun to
like
we um we spend like every minute when
i'm on off the road we spend almost
every minute together like usually he's
driving i like to have a poc drive me um
he's my poc driver but we like he has
like uh in his office he's working on
two netflix shows my boy has our baby
has flown
his hatch but he cannot get him to text
me back todd was editing all of our
podcast stuff for the longest time now
he's
too big for us you are his stepping
stone i know exactly i'm proud to be
have been used by the doormat once again
you let me know
when you have a window
so don't jump out of it todd i need you
um don't defenestrate yourself defend
don't defend a straight yourself
throw someone out of a window
defenestrate why do we need a word for
that how often does that happen because
eric and son did it he defended streets
he's like oh i'm so sick of hearing
cream
was that an aircraft that was the name
of his band i think will you look that
up it hurts oh i'm crushing at the like
i saw you in heaven was about his dead
kid i feel like i should know that it's
not i saw you in heaven
that was my name that was my song on
raya by the way cheers in heaven yeah
uh yes eric clapton was in a band called
cream but wait let me ask you something
what was your ryan song emily
i
don't want to share it with you
absolutely not because you're gonna make
fun of it no of course
we're getting too serious is this your
way did you destroy a boundary now yes
this is my mouth now i don't know last
show we talked about you shitting your
pants i'm not on raya
oh right sorry
cool enough
oh so yours is
your saw no your song is this
your song is just
silence your song is
silent
your song is the songs we used to sing
in quaker
quaker meeting because it's silence
okay this is not fair emily you would
totally get on now when emily applied to
raya which is the dating app that
requires an application and a reference
two shouldn't have those highlights look
at that
this was before this was emily before
when half of her photos were frankly of
her niece and the other half that you
were actually in were out of focus your
instagram was a disaster and they based
it on your instagram well
you missed your chance can i tell you
guys who i met two days ago
who's the brother of the main guy who's
the most recognizable one yeah he was
awesome he came to the doug stand up
show i i was like listen
i know people clown you guys but i want
you to know that every fucking morning
we blast rockstar by nickelback we're
dead serious we're like alexa rockstar
from nickelback that's how we wake up
it's such a pumping like manifestation
thing do you think nickelback knows how
much of it punches
i know because fucking marc maron walked
into the green room and went oh i think
i had a joke about you guys like a punch
line huh mark is so funny marcus
because here's the other thing it's like
i spanked him i brought him up or he
brought me up on the stage and i was
like spanking him so fucking hard never
do that i would be terrified mark maron
terrifies me
okay but here's the thing i feel like as
someone that was kind of a public
punchline for a second and didn't know
like when someone comes up to you and
it's like hey that's crazy you must like
don't worry about them don't worry about
all those jokes about your like what
joke like there was a day where
nickelback didn't know they were a
punchline and i was saying i wrote a
tweet about you i just remembered before
i knew you oh do you wanna know what it
is yes when whitney houston died i go oh
my god whitney got canceled i thought it
was like nbc got cancelled
i was afraid it was like a hacker but i
was the first one to that's really funny
actually it was like oh my god r.i.p
whitney got canceled yeah no
yeah it's my sitcom did drown in about
them
ironically but um uh but it is wild to
know like if what if they didn't know
that they were a punchline yeah no they
but i was i it's kind of like
like selling your soul to the devil like
i want to be like one of the most
popular bands in the world but you
didn't like tell them like
what direction that's what i said to
louie i was like louie i think you
should have been like clearer by your
intentions you're like i want everyone
to know my name think about my deck but
it's also like tricky because i feel
like the main punch lines are
nickelback
toad the red sprocket
dude the what's this they're not made
train
train oh train
store you're gonna do like a random like
shitty band what are you doing
too wait i'm trying to collect train i
have beef with train we're cool now but
we we had fights i was on fire
because i hung out with them once back
and then i actually saw dennis quaid
recently and i was like
do you remember partying in a fucking
hotel room and jamming with train and he
was like oh my god i do
have so many questions okay so i was in
new york i was shooting girl code i came
in um there's this comedian named mad
dog matern who goes by
uh james madden now which is like
actually so annoying i'm like i could
have called you james the whole time and
even because
but so i went to go visit him he is like
he's a really funny comedian who does
like really almost like stream of
consciousness um crowd work loud but he
says like baby weird things so we were
gonna go see my friend anthony devito he
goes he was in times square
and where my hotel was and so james goes
he uh
let's go up come with me i'm gonna go
say anthony he's with train now i
thought he meant like on a train like he
said weird things he's like
trains and your trains and yeah exactly
i was like okay
we go to this hotel
please still doing my catchphrase
um so and it's also what i do on todd
but so i go so i go to um we go into
this lobby of this hotel or this bar and
it's the band train it's anthony with a
band train you don't even realize you
know what train looks like until you see
train and you're like oh i know i know
train pat the main guy okay so so then
me virginia is a banger well how about
drops of jupiter apologize to virginia
is what you should be singing because
remember did you get in trouble with
virginia it was west virginia it was bad
and i'm still getting done meet west
virginia don't meet her
no meat ingredients in west virginia
i'm dead meat in virginia
so um so anyway so i see them and i'm
like oh my god it's train and we're all
like sitting there so it's just anthony
these these three guys that are in the
band there's i think it's a beer band
like their tour manager
and then we're sitting there talking and
then dennis quaid like stumbles in like
i feel like he was shirtless but maybe
he wasn't
he was everyone was drunk okay except me
i was dead sober
so um so they i guess dennis quaid and
pat had seen each other in the
the um elevator and i now know when
you're famous and you live a dream job
you guys you equalize and you you know
each other right away you just kind of
go like oh okay we're well famous we
have a thing yeah so which i'm learning
collecting all green day i'm coming for
you billy joe i'll collect you you'll be
in my harem use green day like you're i
want them i don't know i want them i
just wanted to buy them no i just always
how much money are you making there's
just people i like
had a special feeling about when i was
like growing up that like i mean paulie
shore is one of them sometimes it
doesn't go the way you it doesn't matter
and then it's more about the collection
of it other times you have no idea so
like when tony hawk came on the podcast
i kind of was like okay great in my
brain i kind of taught kevin christie
because you didn't know what to do with
it i was
literally sweating i was like
fumbling like it was like i didn't
realize how big of a part of like my
hippocampus and dna he was that happens
with polly sure still and it's like he
says things that annoy me every time i
talk to him and i still like trip over
my feet when i see him i'm like it's the
fucking weasel where you're like there's
no way to undo how big of a part of my
life you want yes even though we're just
sitting here doing like a fucking
podcast yeah you know what i'm saying so
yeah you can't reverse ollie or whatever
do you feel like like billy joe
armstrong is that for you he's a he's
just one of i just really really really
always like loved green day and i love
billy and i just didn't like that much
music i by the way was just doing this
event in um in utah and jewel was there
and jewel after jules on rogan by the
way jewel on the joe rogan podcast is
that interview is unbelievable
she's my she's my queen because she
lived in her car too she has
such an incredible story you know that
her mom stole 50 million dollars from
her like it is the wildest story she is
all in forgiveness she is you can still
steal 50 million dollars there's only
one person i know or two people i know
with that much money
no
you and my king
i do not have that kind of money i spend
it all on girl scouting she doesn't have
that kind of money i'm just kidding um
and uh i
i
so we were like dm'ing back and forth
and like i like would post videos of me
singing jewel like over there and she
was so thirsty and i know talk but in my
mind i was the k i am fine with being a
fucking dorky fan with someone i
and uh i see jewel and i
like i knew she was gonna be there i
knew and i still she gave me that little
um ukulele and she signed it and drew
goodness
she made that for me and i when i get
really star struck i get rude i just go
like hey and just like walk away like a
guy that has a crush on a girl oh my god
isn't that cute
we call it
she like made that for me and i
completely like disassociated and
couldn't even have a conversation with
her and then she did a private concert
in a hotel room and i watched her sing
right in front of me and i cried the
entire i was sobbing oh that's been so
great for her
what a treat that was for her she had to
get up all early she was like this
bitches i do squirt from my face yeah it
was like a nightmare it was so important
did you see how confident i took this
thinking
yeah i'm trying to see where you're
going i can sort of play like one tiny
thing on a guitar so i was trying to do
it no it doesn't work on here if you
ruin the ukulele jewel gave me i will
sue you
yeah no that doesn't even have the
enough
strings it's not like a guitar it's a
ukulele
if you do something confident enough
like like
oh my god if you if you don't put this
up your pussy i'm going to be so posed
if you just come don't let me down bitch
if you just commit to something and are
just like
we can put some music put some music
over her yeah
it makes it sound like she's so fucking
good please like try to be good keep
doing it and then i'll be like
if i make eye contact with you and just
like
okay so what okay we have to go soon
because we're going to go to the improv
in person i know but i don't want to
stop
okay so then i just have to come back
okay so but so here's the other thing
you didn't say the last three things
besides some trenches uh breathing let
me finish train story and then i'll get
to that and then we'll get back on the
train of thought
um we'll train our brains after i talk
about train so okay so we go to um
we go to
uh we're sitting there dennis quaid
comes up they're fucking bonding they're
wasting what's dennis quaid number one
thing go movie what uh the company inner
interspace
parent
interspace okay dennis quaid by the way
the hottest shit was um when he played
jerry lee lewis what was this uh what
was the movie
i loved that movie and i'm pretty sure i
was related to it show me someone
fucking their 13 year old cousin
make more movies about it how wild i
know
well all these boys will be like well
jerry lee lewis used to do it you're
like
but it was weird
for us to talk about it it was winona
ryder i remember that because i remember
her wearing like really big panties like
she didn't even know about being sexual
yet i had a boyfriend who worked with
her on something and i was like i was
like you have to give me like gossip
about her and he goes oh i'll tell you
something crazy the other day we were in
the office and she didn't know her own
address and i was like oh my god that's
what i aspire to be
to imagine not knowing your own address
that means someone just picked you up
and put you in your car i want that
that's the life i'm looking for
why are you keeping your mouth shut do
you not know your address
do i not aspire to be you
isn't that amazing
i don't know my own address but they're
watching copy and paste it and there
were times i would call emily
that is the i'm telling you when you
were my sister when you were my
assistant or when i moved into the new
house and when i was your assistant
tell the explain give me an example well
like you would just call and be like
what's my address
all right we we really can
wrap it up okay so the train story the
train thing so we go up so anyway
they're talking and then they're like
hey you're wearing a band right and he's
like yeah i jam like you want to go jam
up in our hotel room so i go up to this
hotel room i'm the only girl which by
the way never go to jam with a band
no it was the most fun ever everyone was
being so respectful pat was like i love
comedy i really appreciate comedians
there's so many like parallels with with
musicians and i'm like yeah totally um
but we had fun so we go up to the thing
fucking dennis quaid is like i this was
when he was shirtless he's playing gin
and juice on an acoustic guitar
everything's insane they're playing i
barely listen to music they're playing
all the hits all the songs my dad used
to i know every lyric
for you and dennis yes and my friend
anthony and mad dog mattered and it was
just us and then so it was like amazing
and nobody was hitting on me it was so
cool and i was like guys i gotta shoot
in the morning i gotta go like what a
cool way to leave you know i'm like i'm
like about to go like what a perfect
night and rice i'm about to go the train
guy goes wait aren't you going to fuck
him and points to their tour guide
manager and i went
i took my person i went
train how i was about to leave he was
ruined the best night i just hugged
dennis quaid goodbye i was like gin and
juice on acoustic i was like fuck this
monster you had to do that and so then i
leave and was he joking
yeah but it was like an annoying joke
people like it was a joke i'm a comedian
i know what jokes are no one's laughing
it's like so annoying it's like but you
but whatever now that i'm looking back
on it it was like cutting the tension of
the fact that i was the only girl i just
thought i was being respected as a
person but i've learned from that that's
not really just like it's okay it's not
funny if you're gonna make a joke about
me fucking so at least make it so
but i was pissed but i was pissed i
leave so then i go to um
i we leave and like anthony's like oh
they feel bad they're sorry or whatever
and i'm like whatever
then two years later i'm doing bumber
shoot in seattle and the comedy like
food area is for some reason we can't
find it so we're like in the rain and
they only have like the thing for the
the musical artists
the the catering for them so they let us
in and i walk in and it's fucking trying
to go train we meet again i throw my bag
down they're like we're sorry
and so it was great and i saw them again
we follow each other on twitter it's
tricky because it's like sometimes
people just make
like it was nothing
but especially when you're like a female
comedian or like a female outspoken
woman sometimes it's like people i'm
making a dirty joke the way you do and
you're like i just don't take things
personally like that anymore like it
felt like such an attack but it's like
not but anyway so
um i would recommend
all of those people that i mentioned
mary lou rodriguez is my uh hypnotist
she fucking is blowing my mind it's just
that's in person or is that it
but i i actually am trained in hypnosis
now so i don't know what i'm going to do
with it but something so is bill
cosby and i'm going to use my power the
same way
to walk out one of my eyes do you think
i'm not looking at you
um he was really just aware that's why i
was there
but um
but anyway so that but but ayahuasca was
really incredible for me it was like 30
years of therapy it just really helped
me with a lot of my issues
um
i would just say if you do it make sure
it's like a safe situation because you
don't want to feel nervous there's a lot
of in this new like healing thing where
it's like all this alternative healing
like gurus and stuff a lot of them
you're going to be in the documentary in
two years a lot of them are fucking
creeps like don't go to their house
don't go to their basement trust your
gut like there's a lot of creepy yeah
make sure you find like the right people
get references and stuff yeah and
hypnosis does not involve someone's
penis intervention hypnosis is very
chill so like it's just you know i
talked to my to mary lou um
those one-on-one sessions are just like
she'll talk to me and we kind of like
get to like she's like what are your
goals what are the things that you want
to get that you feel blocked from so if
it's like oh i want to write more jokes
it'd be like why are you writing more
jokes or what you know and then we could
get to like oh there's like this feeling
of like low self-esteem or there's so
like lack of self-love i don't feel like
i deserve it or that my jokes are good
enough or whatever you get to whatever
the issue is so then you find it then
she goes all right she'll go this is my
favorite which is what do you think your
beautiful brain needs to hear so then
you tell her the opposite thing you need
to hear and then she makes an audio for
you where she get does like the
induction where she gets you in
where you're in uh your brain is just
like
at a level where it's more susceptible
to the things around you which is where
people are scared but it's not
i'll get references bitches yeah like
and um
you know and and then you like you put
new um beliefs into your head yeah just
reprogram it's updating your software
it's great anyway i love you yeah i love
you guys so fucking much i never want
you to leave but we have to go thanks
for helping me get rich you said you
were going to do it
and you did it
i love richanne it's my favorite thing
rich annie's just as tacky as poor and
he was it's so great because you're the
same person just it's so fun it's like i
have such a scarcity complex i refuse to
spend money like on anything i will only
buy like vintage watching you just be
like i'm like i want to be like annie
when i grow up dude no i just decided i
wanna and this is actually how more
money has come to me i know this sounds
like totally crazy and obviously like no
i worked really hard to get into this
position where i am but
i just now when i buy things i just go
do i really want this
and sometimes i overbuy but i'm almost
testing myself because i don't want to
have any negative feelings towards money
i just want to think of like jim ford
says he goes like if you were in a
relationship with money yeah if this was
like your loved one you said you're not
enough you're not good enough you're not
that like
they'd feel like shit right but if
you're like i love you you're amazing
they're just gonna get better and better
and better so i just look at it like
like i've just taken out any of the
worry and i just work on when i'm
worried i go what is this about because
if i do run out of money which i have a
million times yeah i'll make more you'll
make more and more there's a million
ways to make money it's like when you're
scared and you're like panicky you're
not thinking you're living from like
victimhood and yeah it's scary city
complex
see how easy it psyched because i was
like okay well least if she runs out of
money and has to live in her car she
gets to live in a day exactly but you
know i'll get parking tickets
okay we're gonna go do the funny ha has
annie letterman um
what what when did i i did an episode of
your podcast i guess it was like three
months ago you matched the background
tuesday it was the most fun and i had
yeah i had such a fucking spiral
afterwards you guys said it was good so
i trust you no it was great you're
always good and then what we talked a
lot about sex stuff on there so go uh
listen to that show please it always
comes back to sex in that part i love
that fucking podcast it's so fun we're
just having such a good time it's so
like it's the best of like it's the best
mix of like roast meats just like dr
drew sex questions meets like yeah
totally it's so fun and like i love like
meeting the fans on the road and stuff
and and it's like it really is like
feels like an honor to perform for them
and they're like we love you like you
got us through tuesday we're like we
fucking love you back like we're so
fucking like podcast fans like we
fucking love thank you for like being
entertained by us we want to entertain
you this trash tuesday annie is also
touring all over
annie letterman.com shows i'm going
fucking everywhere i need to give you a
christmas gift
i love you guys don't write a lupons
[Music]
wow
[Applause]